[Musique]
josée legault jonathan trudeau à la
question gay bonsoir bonsoir
on va et le sujet s'impose on entendu je
peux vous ai entendu marwari ski plutôt
je vais vous le faire en termes de toute
façon dans une seconde mais menaces de
mort contre pana mme rice qui elle rit
coach icaunais dans market se fait
défoncer son bureau de comté
et la véronique disais tout à l'heure ça
m'a frappée il ya eu 2 121 une menace
colligées par la sûreté du québec compte
des élus y en avait eu 16 avant la
pandémie ça donne un peu le temps je
fais entendre madame risques et madame
anglade monsieur legault revient toute
sa première fois que l'on me demande de
rester chez nous d'annuler mes activités
de pas sortir le tenté d'organiser
un peu plus de sécurité pour moi
j'avais quand même sorti j'avais une
échographie là sont passés ces réalités
d'une femme enceinte je peux pas non
plus faire campagne à partir de chez
nous sa première fois que j'étais dans
ma salle de bains pris mes genoux ont
commencé à claquer
la violence a pas sa place dans notre
société puis on a tous un rôle à jouer
là-dedans pour pour baisser le niveau de
le baisser le niveau de tension
c'est inacceptable qui est arrivé au
bureau de monsieur ciccone inacceptable
qui est arrivé à beaucoup de pancartes
on veut un débord on est
chanceux d'avoir la démocratie qu on au
québec l'a donc peu importe le parti
l'heure c'est inacceptable
bon alors que faire on peut la question
josée legault
que faire
mon dieu écoute et j'écrivais justement
là-dessus ce matin vont des solutions il
faudrait commencer par poser le bon
diagnostic et proposer des remèdes moi
je dois dire que je suis très troublé
d'apprendre que la personne qui a menacé
marwari ski à répétition menacé de mort
incluant en connaissant son adresse et
en appelant même dans un poste de police
a été libéré sous condition n'a même pas
été gardé en détention
le temps qu'ils ne puissent le temps que
ça puisse procéder dans quelle sorte de
message laxiste est-ce que ça ça envoie
alors que l'on voit depuis un bon bout
de temps justement les menaces
l'intimidation
augmenté non seulement contre les
politiciens et politiciennes mais contre
nous aussi les journalistes et les
chroniqueurs a donc fait vraiment on est
dans une espèce de vases buzz depuis un
bon bout de temps mais je vous dirai si
vous me permettez
c'est ce que j'ai remarqué peut-être que
je me trompe mais je pense que le
soi-disant convoi de la liberté
d'occupation le pendant plusieurs
semaines de la ville d'ottawa pendant
que les forces policières les deux bras
attachées derrière le dos que les hautes
autorités politiques que cette sphère
les autorités policières
ça a été reçue par plusieurs réseaux de
fanatiques parce que je pense qu'on a
affaire à une montée du fanatisme
antisystème à des politiciens optimedia
très très propre piège ça a été comme
une actuelle de permissions
d'accélérer cette tendance et moi même
je débuts comme journaliste j'ai reçu
des menaces beaucoup plus dure beaucoup
plus vulgaire beaucoup plus gros tiers
les politiciens la même chose il ya
qu'il ya eu il ya eu un point de
non-retour qu'on a franchi avec
l'occupation d'ottawa et je pense que ça
il faut commencer à regarder ça de très
près ce fanatisme la cette
radicalisation là d'une minorité
agissante mais c'est une minorité
croissante
jonathan vos réflexions là dessus puis
un geiq faire c'est ce qu'il n'y a pas
de réponse facile pas c'est un climat
c'est
sa semaine du fait de plusieurs façons
sur les réseaux sociaux des menaces
privé avec s'était relevé que si affreux
l'inde des menaces verbales quand un
politicien devant nous ça c'est un
problème jonathan je pense qu'on doit
piquer vraiment la règle de la de la
tolérance zéro de façon très concrète on
doit mieux protéger certains de nos
politiciens évidemment ce qui s'est
passé au fédéral vous y faisiez
référence est que ce fut l'heure de jeu
pour avons travaillé au fédéral et au
provincial je ne peux pas concevoir
encore à ce jour et encore moins avec le
climat actuel évidemment que les
ministres au fédéral ne soit pas mieux
protégé donc sociale chose pour skins
aux députés je vois pas une façon de
protéger 24 ans ou 24 et sans médecin
député par exemple avec des gardes du
corps mais ce que des moyens concrets
bon maire maurice qui parlait d'un
bouton panique où je pense que des
avenues envisagées mais au lieu de ça il
faut s'assurer aussi que toutes les
personnes qui ont une tribune que ce
soit nous que ce soit les politiques et
les chefs de parti des élus qu'on
s'assure que ces gens le dénonce haut et
fort ce genre de dérapage et patrice je
ne tomberai pas dans le piège de nommer
une personne ou une autre comme étant
à pointer du doigt pour le climat actuel
sauf que ce qu'on sait tous l'éléphant
dans la pièce c'est que dans les
dernières années on a vu que des gens
qui sans être ceux qui vont jeter de
l'huile sur le feu a juste un peu comme
des agitateurs sans appeler à la
violence mais sans la condamner
suffisamment fermement et je pense que
tous doivent être sensibilisés et s'unir
et condamné ça c'est impensable de voir
une femme comme art aux risques et aux
députés comme enrico ciccone ces
employés vont des gens qui veulent
servir et qu'ils en ont des craintes de
sortir d'effectuer leur travail
alex est comme si la parole avait été
libéré chez tous ces gens agressifs la
pandémie a exagéré tout seul on est on
est dans un nouveau monde en tout cas
dans ses réseaux dans cette
communication entre les élus pas juste
les élus mais les élus et et certaines
personnes
la parole c'est une chose mais là en
plus quand on parle d'entrer par
effraction dans un bureau de
circonscription comme celui d'un éco
chic on est ce qu on fait du vandalisme
et on arrache les aussi confidentiel des
citoyens c'est une couche supplémentaire
là on est vraiment rendu dans le passé
de la parole aux actes il ya peu on
n'est pas derrière un clavier quelqu'un
anonymes qui se disent faire des menaces
puis j'ai trouvé ça drôle on est rendus
complètement ailleurs quoi faire avec
succès chez moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de la sécurité des élus
comme dit ma roue ainsi on peut pas
faire campagne de chez soi la politique
inévitablement faire en sorte qu'on
entre en contact avec des gens des
inconnus c'est sur le métier c'est ce
qu'ils font dans la vie alors pour
trouver une manière de les protéger
correctement je suis d'accord avec
jonathan quand il dit il faut que tout
le monde dénonce ça ben je vais vous
donner un exemple très concret à ce jour
on n'a pas dénoncé jeudi à pau lièvre ce
qui s'est passé avec christian friedel
on a dit vite vite quatre jours plus
tard au oui non c'est pas bien mais vous
savez moi aussi je reçois des menaces de
mort il faut vivre avec maintenant non
ce n'est pas ça dénoncé l'agression
verbale comme christophe hullin a vite
eu viol des politiciens encore dans
certains partis dans certaines franges
qui profitent de cette colère qui en ont
fait une partie de leur forme commerce
et qui veulent pas dénoncer ce type
d'agissement là parce qu'un mode alors à
qui ça arrive encore aujourd'hui il ya
un exutoire politique pour ces
personnes-là puis je suis d'accord avec
jonathan devraient les fermer ses
exutoire maintenant apprécier
concrètement dans la police à
l'assemblée nationale aux partis
politiques de se demander comment on
pourrait faire un meilleur encadrement
sécuritaire de nouveaux élus les jauger
sur les arrange louis josé houde mais je
pense qu'il faut nommer ou s'ils
allaient bien de nommer pierre poilievre
ci ne dénonce pas c'est parce que
justement c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
associé avec ce qui s'est passé à ottawa
c'est quelqu'un qui a instrumentalisé ce
qui s'est passé à ottawa
est ce qu'on a vu au bureau du député tu
connais ça vient aussi de cette culture
là que s'est installée à yuya plus
seulement des menaces pendant le convoi
de la liberté ya eu du vandalisme aussi
l'appeler forces policières ont laissé
des ddd supposé manifestants entré par
effraction dans des magasins entrer dans
des blocs appartements
ça et toute cette agressivité la non
seulement verbale mais physique aussi
ont reçu la permission d'exister en sol
canadien moi je n'en démord pas on a
vécu quelque chose de déterminant je
l'avais écrit à l'époque j'espère me
tromper que ça annonçait ce qui s'en
venait et une fois que ça a été terminé
une fois que la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence et adopter une fois que tout
le monde est rentré chez lui au bout de
quelques semaines on a mis ça sous le
boisseau puis on espérait que ça ne
pullulent rep ah mais non ça pue le
voilà et hier à l'air et s ces
différents messages on parle de la même
chose du grand grand ensemble de la
viola dans son cas il il a envoyé une
vidéo que vous voyez en disant moi je
vais arrêter je vais bloquer tout le
monde parce que j'en peux plus je fais
j'en vois un poste insignifiant sur la
rentrée scolaire ça a vraiment
d'impliquer de connotations politiques
et les messages de violence de hargne
que je reçois alors il à faire ce cri du
coeur que vous voyez hier député
conservateur donc ça touche tout le
monde ayant leur ras-le-bol devant ça en
même temps lui même le dit dans sa vidéo
et c'est délicat alex que c'est la
liberté d'expression à l'as où tu m'as
la ligne info que c'est très délicat à
gérer ce pas facile non plus saine et la
liberté d'expression c'est ce que je
m'en allais faisait la liberté
d'expression c'est la liberté de dire
n'importe quoi donc et qui est pas
d'accord avec nos idées les politiques
sont capables de vivre avec ce sont
confrontés à ça tout le temps moi même
sur les réseaux sociaux ce que josé
j'attends aussi des gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec ceux qui lui disent une
façon polie de le faire une façon d'être
en désaccord tout à fait correct même
intéressant parfois d'avoir un autre son
de cloche plus on en débat un peu mais
là se faire menacer de mort par insulter
dit qu'on va s'en prendre à sa femme à
ses enfants dans le cas d'alain rey est
complètement déplacé est-ce qui peut
supprimer ces messages le you bet qui
peut les supprimer il devrait le faire
pour sa santé mentale et policiers ont
fait endurer n'importe quoi
jonathan
élément supplémentaire le dans la
réflexion évidemment la crainte première
c'est pour la sécurité le physique de
ses hommes et de ses femmes l'homme est
l'autre élément c'est le risque d'un
désengagement accru de personnes qui
décident de faire des sacrifices pour
aller faire de la politique c'est déjà
pas évident on l'a vu dans les dernières
années avec avec notamment les des
médias sociaux des hommes et des femmes
qui font d'énormes sacrifices des
sacrifices au niveau de la famille des
sacrifices parfois financiers des
sacrifices et le risque au niveau
réputationnel il ya plein de sacrifices
à faire de risques à prendre se lance en
politique
faisons en sorte que de moins en moins
de gens veulent le faire et le si on
ajoute à ça le risque en plus pour sa
propre sécurité pour la sécurité des
déjà avec qui travaille la sécurité de
leurs familles parce que m'a donné son
nom au sud démocratie c'est un une
démocratie dynamique faux pas de tout
faire ou tout accepter que va faire en
sorte que les ces personnes là ne
voudront plus rien sa ronde la politique
georget conclusion
c'est ça mais je pense qu'on vit un
moment de contagion du tropisme kaki
vraiment qui a traversé la frontière et
là les forces policières ont du travail
aussi à faire du travail dans quai du
travail de surveillance des médias
sociaux pour les élus mais aussi pour
les journalistes
et j'insiste particulièrement pour les
femmes parce que ce qu'on reçoit c'est
extrêmement agressant donc il ya quelque
chose qui bouillonne quelque chose d'
extrêmement malsain et on peut pas juste
dénoncer là il va falloir qu'il ya des
lois qui soit plus dur il va falloir on
a parlé pour la violence armée à
montréal va falloir qu'il ya des lois
plus dur il va falloir qu'il ya des
enquêtes à des arrestations
puis quand quelqu'un se fait arrêter
leur se faire libérer sous conditions
comme ça après avoir menacé une lune
membres je le répète je n'en reviens pas
très bien autre sujet qui s'est imposé
dans la campagne électorale gnl québec
pas s'exciter mort et enterré or
louis blouin et notre collègue de tahoua
raconte dans un texte intéressant ce
matin le ministre sy given dans des
échanges avec ottawa des échanges qui
préparatoire pour la venue du chancelier
alma et ils ont parlé de quoi le
chancelier monsieur trudeau d'énergie
d'exportation de gaz naturel
éventuellement on faisait le point de
tous les dossiers au canada + lui aurait
dit pas écouté on verra peut-être pas
mort puis on va peut-être ouvrir ce qui
a obligé monsieur legault à dire ceci
plomb défilent les autres réactions
you le gouvernement fédéral qui essaie
d'aider l'allemagne pour ni d'accord
avec sa part quand il n'ya pas
d'acceptabilité sociale on parlerait
d'avoir un tuyau qui passerait québec
donc ça touche pas juste le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean puis donc le bac
le rejeter donc rien de changé de ce
côté là où fermé la porte à tout jamais
à ce projet là c'est fermé
comprend que monsieur fils but n'est pas
mal plus d'accord avec nos positions
parti conservateur qu'avec celle de son
chef françois le goûte
et
évidemment on accepte tous la bonne
décision que le québec a prise que ce
n'était pas le bon projet au niveau
environnemental
si des gens veulent ramener un nouveau
projet un projet différent mais ça
passera les étapes réglementaires au
québec et au canada s'il ya lieu
jonathan ce que la porte est fermée à
tout jamais
m'ont dit qu'elle est complètement con
est complètement fermé le est ce que
monsieur fils guy bono prêcher par excès
d'enthousiasmé d'optimisme qui les a il
est jamais totalement fermé à au moins à
temps de parler d'un bon projet mais il
n'avait pas un mode par exemple décidé
de rouvrir ce dossier là et le terme
rouvrir il est important parce que à la
fin de la journée on est tous là
discuter de gnl québec on voit que tu
une opportunité intéressante pour les
partis d'opposition d'essayer de mettre
monsieur legault en porte à faux mais il
n'existe pas le projet réalité c'est que
ce projet là il n'existe pas il n'y a
pas de financement il n'a pas de contrat
d'approvisionnement une source qui me
disait essentiellement le projet gnl
québec c'est un monsieur qui se promène
avec un point dans sa valise et des
fonds de support à ce moment c'est sur
le projet gnl québec et même si le
canada avait la préparation de voulons
ramier aider l'allemagne l'allemagne
veut pouvoir s'approvisionner à assez
court terme alors que des projets comme
ceux qu'on mentionne prendrait plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs années donc dans les
faits c'est même pas une solution pour
l'allemagne qui risquent de
s'approvisionner ailleurs sur la planète
donc on parle un peu pour rien dit parce
que le projet il n'existe pour
concrètement vous dites que ça ça coûte
pas grand chose amusante rassure le bape
l'avait rejetée sur québec mais ça coûte
pas grand-chose à monsieur le goût de le
fermer de toute façon il n'y a pas de
vrai projet véritable derrière jauger
non mais je pense qu'on a à faire
beaucoup aussi à une valse très très
très politique pleine campagne
électorale donc on a évidemment de côté
irin gm pour qui le combat contre les
changements climatiques passe par le
développement des hydrocarbures
cherchez l'erreur bon alors il fait du
millage là dessus et puis évidemment en
beauce et ses populations menées ces
populaires bon parfait mais ce convoi
c'est peut-être du côté du gouvernement
trudeau parce que bon ça vient de là
cette supposée informations lors que
monsieur dugué but ne
aimerait bien là c'est le projet après
le 3
octobre fait un petit bout mrai aussi
pour ce que monsieur legault a fait part
à la campagne électorale fédérale ce
qu'il avait appelé carrément les
québécois à ne pas voter pour le parti
libéral donc y aurait-il le petit boom
rails
je vous vois avec une petite boucle et
rouge douce ouais ouais c'est la mode
mais pas maïs et
la deux c'est la deuxième plus
redevables qui vient d'ottawa à la
première c'est le pont de québec ou
juste avant la campagne on commence à
discuter de ce que québec avait oui dit
oui dit non pour acheter le pont club 1
3 sources et louis blouin et travaille
bien notre collègue est un bon
journaliste trois sources différentes à
ottawa ça veut dire que des gens qui ont
des idées de plats côté on essaie de
josi 19 des voix le plein
alors que jonathan raison là ya pas de
projets steven guilbeault aussi fermé la
porte pour l'oublier at hawaï à l'époque
question ce projet long littoral en
terre et le soudainement des discussions
de corridor il ya un autre jour la haute
école demande a perfé tribune
éventuellement peut-être que peut-être
on en reparlera plus haut qu'on le
discute par un journaliste pour ce mode
de vote rendre plus facilement certains
sujets quoi depuis la dernière les
clients maintenant on savait que ça
allait faire jaser et puis que c'est
réussi une pelure de banane c'est réussi
on n'a pas réussi ce texte cela fait
jaser toute la journée pour ma part les
six pieds voilà
je n'attache commencé avec vous on
certains ont découvert depuis quelques
jours que le plq n'était plus le plq
d'autres fois il manque des candidats on
va écouter madame anglade qui je crois
reconnaître que
yann côte à monter on écoute
on joue à l'offensive alors c'est sûr
que tu as une stratégie où on joue à
l'offensive ça peut paraître difficile
mais nous on veut être une alternative
pour toutes les régions du québec que
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça qu'on va
continuer à être sur le terrain dans
différentes régions
un autre candidat dans en estrie cette
fois ci que s'est désisté il leur en
manque une quinzaine au plq jonathan
comment vous voyez ce début de campagne
est ce que c'est vraiment surprenant
compte tenu de ce qu'on sait depuis
plusieurs plusieurs mois ça va pas bien
dans l'appui populaire de ce parti a
mais je leur ai jamais pensé que ce
serait aussi pire que ce soit pour le
parti libéral du québec l'ont il manque
encore une quinzaine de candidats des
candidats 1 après longue qui ce qu'ils
se désistent on va chercher des employés
politiques côté je me demande même qui
reste dans le royaume le fameux la
fameuse salle stratégique du parti vert
du québec on a l'impression que tous les
acteurs autour de dominique anglade ont
été dépêchés dans un comté ou un autre
sauf que le problème à aller chercher de
bonnes candidatures il était invoquée il
était connu depuis déjà quelques
semaines ce qui me frappe depuis le
début de la campagne c'est la mauvaise
organisation de la campagne de mener
quand gilad et jetaient nuance madame
anglade elles performent bien elle est
dynamique ne semble pas baisser les bras
mais il ya des choix absolument douteux
inexplicable qui sont fait faire des
annonces économiques sans l'équipe
économique passé près de trois jours à
québec en début de campagne alors que
croyez moi je suis à même de prendre des
points au québec il ya aucune espèce de
guerre pour le parti libéral à québec se
déplacer dans un rassemblement militant
dans montmagny et avec une trentaine de
personnes on me dit que des députés
sortants des anciens qui avait levé la
main qui avait dit on pourrait peut-être
aidé à l'organisation de la campagne
c'est ses offres l'ont été ignorés bah
c'est le résultat qu'on connaît à ce
moment là alec
n'avait pas d'attaché de presse dans
notre ve des médias jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on fait des points presse à contre jour
les caméras sont obligés d'user la
dominique anglade de se déplacer parce
qu'on on est malgré vu l'homme seul ace
et toutes sortes de petits détails qui
peuvent avoir l'air anodin et messieurs
les cas pas capable de régler comme du
papier à musique la logistique on peut
parler du contenu si le contenant est
tout croche en politique il faut
commencer par savoir où on voit à quel
endroit on présente nos candidats qui
vont être sur place et ensuite qu'il
quel candidat va être avec nous on parle
de jonathan par l'équipe économique une
évidence que l'équipe connaît mais que
réduite avec dominique anglade à québec
m'ont aidé mais nos missions à montréal
mais bon dieu fait de leur rendre la
veille leur auto l'autobus
québec et ça c'est des erreurs que le
parti libéral ne faisait pas avant vous
n'auriez pas vu se fait dépouiller ans
où jean charest et dominique anglade et
les bonnes je suis d'accord avec
jonathan je sais pas comment on fait
pour garder le sourire pour être
dynamiques comme ça chaque jour en
sachant que les tuiles tombe plus tard
parce que bon dieu autour d'elle ça
commence à être un champ de ruines
jauger
oui ben écoutez si je pense qu'on avait
vu venir le problème des candidatures il
ya plusieurs mois lorsqu'on avait vu je
pense c'est la première fois qu'on vient
sur le parti libéral qui avaient placé
des annonces un peu sur le web pour vous
s'il vous plaît candidats le parti
libéral du québec comme un heureux
c'était juste c'est elle signe qu'il y
avait un gros problème de recrutement
c'est pourquoi il ya moins 10 % chez les
francophones n'y a rien de très très
attirant moi je veux bien que madame
anglade soit dynamique qu'elle soit
bonne humeur qu'elle soit optimiste
malgré la tempête mais un moment donné
c'est elle la chef du parti et ça ne
tiendra pas pendant toute la campagne
que c'est la faute des autres autour où
sont les autres qu'ils ont c'est elle la
chef d'orchestre lol donc que si elle ne
redresse pas la situation d'ici peu là
on va arrêter de pointer son entourage
puis on va pointer la chine merci
beaucoup à vous droit bonne soirée à
très bientôt